une façon de parler parce que c'est pas
si brutale que ça sont donc les gens qui
ont posé des questions sur le minitel
vous l'avez vu 36 15
mp3 et je me fais leur porte-voix à la
rue première question vous demande
pourquoi dans vos clips vous êtes
sourcil provocatrice s'il vous plaît par
goût de la provocation voilà une phrase
bien course est très pertinente en est
pas mal parce que j'aime provoquer que
ce n'est pas mon seul but
non
mais c'est vrai que j'ai un goût pour la
provocation comme certainement pierre
péan fin de bouder des choses un peu
chocs bas donc c'est réussi merci alors
est une mariée nous demande tom non je
suis célibataire et je vis avec un
capucin qui n'est pas un moine mais un
petit singe qu'est ce qu'elle relie des
caisses a fait quelle taille ça c'est
capucins est grand comme ça une très
longue queue est à peu près le ton de
vos chaussures à jour merci
et quant à jean cyr est plutôt ils ne
sont pas si rares mais j'ai fait exprès
je me suis dit comme ça ça sera plus
encore
bref connaissiez les capucins professeur
véhicule son petit change d ici
absolument délicieux vie dure et à
manger
non non non non non nous restons dans le
domaine moral par les provocations tout
à l'heure j'ai déjà pris une provocation
gustatives d'accord d'autres questions
alors on nous demande on nous demande ça
c'est peut-être un peu plus sévère avez
vous l'impression qu'il restera quelque
chose qu'on se souviendra des chansons
bien de farmer dans quelques années
c'est une question à laquelle vous ne
serez pas répondre donc est-ce que ça
vous importe qui nous reste quelque
chose à votre avis si on fait ce métier
c'est qu'on a envie d'y laisser quelques
plumes et quelques traces bien sûr ça
m'importe c'est que je que je vais tout
faire pour qu'on n'oublie pas c'est bien
marquer la provocation on est un peu lié
d'ailleurs et oui bon on vous demande ça
je suppose c'est un homme c'est dommage
qu'il a pas laissé son nom il vous
demande quel type d'homme vous appréciez
dans la vie quel type d'homme je ne
pense pas avoir des capucins où il
aurait pu répondre ça
encore une question très difficile
j'aime plutôt je crois les hommes les
hommes dits intellectuels entre
guillemets somme toute un groupe ici non
je veux dire par là c'est vrai que je
suis fasciné par les métier d'écrivain
journalistes mais mais c'est idiot comme
portrait je comptais arrêter ce que vous
savez c'était plus terre à terre c'était
physiquement physiquement alors plutôt
grand 1 plutôt des cheveux longs efforts
ni de bernard henri lévy alors par
exemple il sera notre invité dans
quelques semaines celle actuelle et je
n'engage que vous eh bien on menti vous
avez fait des études
non j'ai fait des études je suis allé
jusqu en fin de première
une première après j'ai abandonné puis
j'ai commencé l'équitation avec
assiduité puis ensuite je me suis tourné
vers le théâtre
ok et la toute dernière question est ce
que est ce que ce convoi de vous est ce
que c'est vous ou bien est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas peu préfabriqués nous
demandent de laurence je crois que oui
encore une question qui est très étrange
préfabriqués c'est difficile vous savez
je pense qu'on peut être pré fabriqués
sur un disque sur cinq disent + 1 album
c'est très difficile que moi j'aime ce
que je fais j'aime ce que je propose et
j'essaye d'aimer ce que je suis donc au
diable la préfabrication parfait belle
conclusion
merci merci à vous s'était pas trop n'y
sommes pas trop beau
[Musique]